let's say that we have the linear
equation y is equal to one half x
one half x
minus three
so if we wanted to draw the line that
represents the set of all points all the
coordinates where the x value and the y
value satisfy this equation well we
could start off by just trying to draw
by trying to
by trying to draw a few of those points
and then connecting them with the line
so let's set up a little table here x
comma y
and then we could just try out a couple
of x values here then figure out what
the corresponding y values are and i'm
going to pick x values where it's going
to be fairly easy to calculate the y
values so let's say when x is equal to 0
then you're going to have one half times
zero minus three well then y is going to
be
negative three
when x is let's see let me try x is
equal to two because then one half times
two is just going to be one
so when x is equal to two you're gonna
have one half times two is one
minus 3 is
negative 2
when x is equal to let's try 4
so 1 half times 4
is 2
and then minus 3 is
negative 1
and we could keep going but actually all
we do need all we need is two points for
a line so we're ready to plot this line
if we'd like the point 0 comma negative
3 is on this line
0 comma negative 3 and actually let me
do this in a slightly darker color so we
can see it on this white background
0 comma negative 3 is on the line 2
comma negative 2 is on the line
so 2 comma negative 2
and then we have 4 comma negative 1. so
when x is four
y is negative one
and i could draw i could draw a line
that connects
that connects all of these so it would
look something like
if i let's see if i can do this so it
would look something like it would look
something
like
like that so this right over here this
is literally this is the graph of
y is equal to
one half x
minus three
now when we look at a graph like this an
interesting thing that we might want to
ask ourselves
is where does the graph intersect our
axes so first we could say well where
does it intersect our
x-axis and when you look at this it
looks like it happens at this point
right over here and this point where a
graph intersects an axes this is called
an intercept and this one in particular
is called the x-intercept
why is it called the x-intercept because
that's where the graph is intersecting
the x-axis and the x-intercept it looks
like this is at the point
comma 0. now it's very interesting the
x-intercept happens when y is equal to
zero remember you're on the x-axis when
you haven't moved up or down from the
from that axis which means y is equal to
zero so your x-intercept happens at x
equals six y equals zero it's this
coordinate now what about the
y-intercept
well the y-intercept is this point right
over here this is where you intersect or
i guess you could say intercept the
y-axis so this right over here
that over there is the y-intercept
and the y-intercept is at the coordinate
that has a 0 for the x-coordinate x is 0
here and y is negative 3.
x is 0 and y is negative 3. this was
actually one of the points that or one
of the the the pairs that we first tried
out and you can validate that six comma
zero satisfies this equation right over
here if x is six one-half times six is
three minus three is indeed equal to 0.
so now that we know what an x-intercept
is it's the point where a graph
intersects the x-axis or intercepts the
x-axis and the y-intercept is the point
where graph intercepts the y-axis or
intersects the y-axis let's try to see
if we can find the x and y-intercepts
for a few other for a few other linear
equations
so let's say
let's say that i have the linear
equation
let's say that i have 5 x
5x plus 6y
is equal to
is equal to 30. encourage you to pause
this video and figure out what are the x
and y intercepts for the graph that
represents the solutions all the xy
pairs that satisfy this equation
well the easiest thing to do here
let's see what
what the what the y value is when x is
equal to zero and what the x value is
when y is equal to 0. when x is equal to
0 this becomes 6y equal 30 and so 6
times what is 30 well y would be equal
to 5 here
so when x is 0 y is 5 and what about
when y is zero well when y is zero
that's going to be zero and you have
five x is equal to thirty well then x
would be equal to six
then x would be equal to six
so we could plot those points zero comma
five when x is 0 y is 5
and when
and when x is 6 y is 0.
so those are both points
on this graph and then the actual graph
is going to
or the actual line that represents the x
and y pairs that satisfy this equation
is going to look like
it's going to look like this
i'll just try
so i can make it go
it's going to look like it's going to go
through those two points
and so it's going to and i can make it
go the other way too
let me see
it's going to go through those two
points
so it's going to look something like
that
now what are its x and y-intercepts
well we already kind of figured it out
but the intercepts themselves these are
the points on the graph where they
intersect the axes
so this right over here this is the
y-intercept that point is the
y-intercept and it happens
it's always going to happen when x is
equal to zero and when x is equal to
zero we know that y is equal to five
it's that point the point zero comma
five
and what is the y-intercept so what is
the x-intercept the x-intercept is the
point it's actually the same x-intercept
for that other for this equation right
over here it's the point six
comma zero
that point right over there